all right and we are live fix your face
travis and welcome
to the last word good lord cognito
ivantas thai guy travis fresh on that
thursday evening campfire very eventful
start to the show and i anticipate a
very eventful show indeed
what is going on with the cheetah first
ibatis how we doing sir
we are doing good uh i have actually
been working on a little early access
preview so i'm trying to get my you know
yeah a little little something
okay all right so yeah
i like that might actually see if i
might actually do a little might see if
i can put together a review i reached
out to travis nicely and he's like you
know he might even give me a few
pointers and stuff so we'll see
okay content creation reviews and early
act okay we'll see we'll see the one i
really wanted to cover actually came out
early access for the content creators
because i think i missed the windowed x
ask for the code today
uh it's cult of the lamb and i don't
know if you guys have seen that one
starting to get streamed it looks i
played the demo and it was like just
long enough that i was like i want more
to really like perfectly time the demo
but like cult of the lamb is a little
rogue-like with you know kind of a
dungeon crawler but also a little
town management sim thing at the same
time
it was
very bizarre but also
like very cute and fun
so that i'm looking forward to but that
comes out like thursday next week so
i'll definitely be giving that one a try
but the other game i was trying um
yeah i will i will see if i can put my
words together on that i just don't want
to say too much on it for now so i'll
tell you guys after a friend hey let's
go yeah other than that uh just kind of
we got three weeks so i've just been
slowly like jump on here do a few
bounties start stockpiling those because
we got like the three-day rush of i'm
already gonna have to make like content
explain how the new season loop works
what's the new event and all that
stuff's coming up so i know
and then the raid theoretically might
get some of the old crew back together
but probably have a few gaps in there
since i know nomad is traveling all over
the place right now so we'll have to see
but we'll see what the raid is and
looking forward to the 23rd travis what
you been up to man i know you got your
big reprieve from xenoblades did you go
outside and touch grass finally
i did not dude i got in i got a review
assigned to me the day after xenoblade
was done i am
fortunately another really long anime
game so i am
doing
that i am is it like a tower of fantasy
that one that just dropped or no
no i'm 30 hours into digimon survive
which is talking about that um a visual
novel that's also a tactics game and
uh the reason i
ended up reviewing it is because
we were supposed to get a code while i
was still reviewing xenoblade but they
ended up not giving early access codes
and just kept saying they were going to
give them to us and then they we didn't
get a code until the day the game came
out
which by that point i was done with
xenoblade and available to do it and uh
yeah it's just a really long game and i
have to do it as quickly as possible
since the game is already out i'm
probably not going to be done this week
i'm 30 hours into it and i don't feel
like i'm close to the end so wow uh it's
going to be a weekend i know what i was
listening to uh beyond they were talking
about games
that like potentially could have been
too long or like overstayed and i think
it was jada who said a previous digimon
game
was like
was already long enough but then if you
played for a certain amount of time your
digimon like got old and you had to
re-hatch them so it just like
artificially kind of extended it as well
and it was another digimon game and i
think she said she was starting the one
you were talking about too which
she wasn't sure how long it was gonna be
or he yeah
yeah well it's a visual novel so you can
probably get through pretty quickly but
um yeah i mean i can talk about it
because the game is out i'm not under
any kind of embargo but
uh it's you know it's a it's a it's a
pretty decent visual novel so far uh
tells a pretty good story it looks
really good it looks like you're
watching an anime it's really cool um
the combat is basically like fire emblem
and it's pretty
mid it's not it's not the best technical
combat so it does really well in the
visual novel stuff it's i would say it's
like 80 a visual novel and 20
a tactics game if that um it probably if
anything less of a tactics game but the
tactics combat ends up being kind of
yeah at least so far i don't i don't
know how far close i am to beating the
game but i'm pretty i'm pretty decently
through it um so yeah i'm doing that and
then i'm working on a preview
construction simulator which will also
go live
next week uh probably not as good as
power wash but you know yeah we'll see
we'll see man
you know
but as we talked about last week i'm
living up to my uh my father's
hopes and dreams for me
i've been doing that all week too yeah
construction workers i've been doing
stuff around my house before the new
season of destiny so it just keeps going
but
what about you what have you been up to
just uh slowly getting back into it man
get my get my destiny shoes back on it's
time to come back home
i was away so i've been slowly just kind
of knocking out a lot of the uh busy
work obviously parasite was done
um just looking at things that i think
arc 3.0 might synergize well so um i
didn't realize i was one uh red border
away from insidious so from crafting one
yeah so i need to get in the valve
unfortunately but i'm going away from
submission i probably shouldn't like i
need to run one with you and just like
go through hit the symbols and at least
let me craft one more weapon
i just need one more i'm thinking about
that
looking at risk what i'm looking at um i
finished the catalyst for um uh overture
which i didn't realize i didn't complete
so i finished that catalyst for grand
overture and then um just synergize just
seeing what might be the next thing you
know oh no risk runner i think will be
substantially
like in play and then what's the bow i'm
thinking of that everybody that i love
now trinity ghouls
like i still don't have it so i gotta
get storm chasers so those i'm just
doing my last couple of busy work while
doing socials but enough about yeah
trespassing y'all shout out to dj what's
going on shout out to the past side
mission g-man yeah i loved it it was
really funny hilarious i love the
platform aspect the voice sounds like an
old old person
but anyway we have a guest that's been
very patient indeed and uh
bring this person in so if you guys are
not watching the audio or watching the
video please check out the video skip
forward right here because you guys have
noticed there's been a coffee cup on
stream
so let me start this right welcome to
the last word episode number 209 the
first thing i want to address is the
harassment that bungie devs have
received and it's worse than we even
know no person deserves to be treated
this way and some of the developers
that i've seen it's just absolutely
awful so please i just want to ask you
guys to stop breathe and eat a banana to
help balance out the heaping amounts of
salt in your life
but really it's only a video game so
please there are much more important
things to worry about in the world let
that stuff go
shout out real quick to the super chat
which we'll play into this one
um with that psa out of the way the
anticipation for the future of destiny
is building as we get ever closer to the
showcase and crucible is once again the
main topic of the discussion
and we once again have a perfect guest
to discuss the world of pvp
gaming for our guest started when he got
his first console that fitted his hand
and his gaming passion only grew
from there
like many previous guests he found halo
and since then fps's have been kind of
his number one but his destiny journey
has been a bumpy road until he found the
most peculiar of ways to get into this
wonderful community with a pants-wearing
train conductor as a shepherd if you
catch a stream of his you are bound to
have a hilarious time and if you're
watching the video you also already are
laughing i'm pretty sure
never taking anything too seriously and
having success with some of the craziest
challenges and builds you may have ever
heard of flawless trials won't run with
only a glaive meaning a bow mostly
because it scares the other teams all
that while raising while helping raise
over 20 000 for charity and the bungee
foundation and bring joy and laughter to
all those around him so let's welcome a
man who plays destiny exclusively on
stadia yes he mains the google streaming
platform hates bananas and yet uses one
as his avatar so i feel there's a sodium
potassium imbalance we must discuss
and has been to the lighthouse with many
many people in his back backpack he also
enjoys a good donut every now and then
and wakes up each and every day and
chooses violence for his twitter posts
welcome to the show the one the only man
who actually sleeps in a banana hammock
stadium time how you doing so hello how
how's it going hey sorry i i don't
actually play destiny 2. i i gotta come
i gotta be honest with you i haven't i
haven't played destiny 2 in a long time
it's been it's it's been like two weeks
i'm gonna be honest with you i've been
i've been busy you know less than two
weeks is a long time in the destiny
universe you lose things for two weeks
and you're already like missed half the
season so like i'm scared
i gotta get back in you already missed
the fall of stadia in that time okay um
yeah i think they call uh i think the
the nine of us left are still playing
okay
leave me alone
i think i think they call two weeks one
stadia of time
because how long that platform lasted uh
time
you know you know it's it's still living
you know
it might be on its last legs or
something i don't know i there was like
a whole thing that happened like the
past weekend where everyone was like
stadia is finally shutting down and you
hear that like every single month for
like the past three years and i'm like
yeah i mean if it does oh well but like
we're still alive so
you know we're having a good time isn't
it actually shutting down though like no
no no no there's a rumor
that's right no google google
legitimately had to make like an
announcement and say like guys like
we're not shutting down what the hell
cool you know so yeah it's still it's
still living i enjoyed my time with it
yeah no it was uh listen stadia was the
number one reason that i even got
introduced to any of this stuff right
and i got introduced to so many content
creators just because of stadia you know
and just a few chance meetups all of a
sudden uh which we can get into a little
bit later about like trials and the
cheaters and like
all that fun stuff
while you shift your banana arms or kind
of doing the whatever you know
oh this is hilarious to watch um cog
would you like to leave off getting to
know our banana guests so much to know
so what you know so
start with gabe history i saw some some
things in the history that really piqued
my interest and i just wanted to know
like from your standpoint what was
actually
the first thing i know we're gonna get
to that steven and get to everything
else but like what are those first
things that gravitated you towards video
games in general
oh gosh well the first video game that i
ever got was pokemon emerald on the
gameboy
and it just felt like a really nice
release you know that's the most things
with every single game you know
regardless if you're playing dark souls
3 and you're like ripping your hair out
and having a horrible time until you
finally beat the boss 70 times i you
know don't ask me i definitely don't
know that
um or you're playing like something like
i don't know like candy crush whatever
right oh they're they're just things
they're little distractions out of your
day but you can really get into them and
pokemon it really gave me that kind of
outlet back at the time to really just
be able to sit down and just enjoy it
and listen to the music that they had at
the time and i i loved it and since then
then i got you know like i got a game
boy and i got all these other games on
there or not a gameboy started gamecube
same thing um and then move the move to
ps1 and then ps2 and then uh what we
said earlier about halo when xbox one
came out and the original halo came out
that immediately that yeah that that
game
sold me on first-person shooters
from the get-go um right away i i
started only really wanting to play
those games because
being able to put yourself in the
perspective of that character because
it's in first person it feels a little
bit more personable it feels like you're
there and that's what i really really
enjoyed about it and so you know then
things progressed and you know black ops
1 came out and that was really the first
actual multiplayer game that i really
played that was first person shooter and
something about yeah yeah seriously
beautiful game and something about going
against other players with um
how do you put this like with the
mindset of i'm putting my skills against
your skills and who can aim at the head
and point faster and more accurate right
like that that was always a really
exciting thing to do and so i that's
from there on because of black ops 1
halo got me into first person shooters
but black ops 1 got me into first person
multiplayer shooters and you know then
destiny ended up coming out and before
it came out actually those little game
remember that gameplay trailer they
showed in the first opening um with the
uh with the with the one fallen captain
or so and they had they had i think it
was a thunderlord
thunderlord and then there was a sniper
rifle the one where you aimed down
sights and it made you invisible do you
remember
patients in time
seeing that trailer
just
unlocked some hidden part inside of me
where i was like magic
first person
loot
guns
enemies i love it yeah you know it was
fantastic i i i was so i was so just
entranced by it and then seeing the
concept art i brought up in in the in
the listing there that there was this
one very specific concept concept art
and that's the reason why every single
one of my characters are exo i think it
might have been in the um in the first
mission opening where you there's an exo
with sitting on the ground leaning back
with its head with its gun on its side
yes
yes yes that was supposed to be rasputin
oh really yeah yeah
i'm learning things still
yeah
that image for some reason just kind of
gave me a vibe of what that game was
supposed to feel like especially the
opening where you see the the fallen
crush the skull of the of the skeleton
that's in the car and you start inside
there and you go through and
you know looking back uh destiny won my
goodness like
it was such a it was such a fantastic
experience to having played that game
reminded me so much of halo you know
came from the same developers but i mean
same you know different different same
same but different
um and yeah no it just
sold me from there i you know i did have
a few life stuff that did come up at
some point and i did have to stop
playing the game and then
um i'm not talking too much i could get
into how i got into destiny 2. right
before you do that
your your history is very similar to
mine as far as um fps and
you know for um halo obviously the feel
of the gun play the music you know the
story first person or console it was
just a thing it was an event right but
it's funny what you said because i
didn't now i look back at it i'm trying
to figure out what was it about call of
duty that made me betray halo for a
while and it was that competitive aspect
including the 60 fps including black ops
with you know prestiging in the
competition and that that constant chase
right for okay if i get this and i
unlock this and
then you saw other people in the lobby
you they're things that they had it
showed their prestige and what it was a
thing right so it's funny you say that
because that literally drew me into it
and then obviously destiny very similar
background meaning in that sense because
it was the wonder of destiny it was just
like wow what is this game it seems
massive and you see the the the concept
art and all this other stuff so it's
funny you said it because we kind of
have similar histories that are fps
stuff like that but i will open it back
up to e because i know we got to get
into the mirror travis
and travis i did the big intro how he
got into destiny i just wanted to hear
that story yeah
before he does though i just have to say
i've never seen
a banana be so passionate and the more
animated
the more animated you get well i know it
is amazing more facial expressions where
he's just like oh my god looting oh no
yeah when you were like enemies and the
eyes went wide i was like please guys if
you catch this on video
go watch like some of this or catch it
on audio go find the video because the
banana is sitting in a coffee cup that's
expressive and wide-eyed and it's
amazing
yeah anyway i want to hear how you got
into destiny you you emphatic banana
oh thank you god you're so cute uh well
i was gonna say well first of all i
wanted to say in halo in multiplayer you
didn't get to actually make loadouts
correct if i remember correctly
that was great like all the halo games
you never got to make loadouts that
actually want to bring up with black ops
1 the reason why i got into it so much
was you could make a loadout right and i
think that's why with destiny it with
with its pvp i know destiny's pvp might
not be the most competitive thing
compared to other games but there's
still a competitiveness to it for the
people who play it right and so having
that kind of way where you make loadouts
from weapons you find or weapons that
you farmed was like a whole nother way
to play a first person shooter in my
opinion that just made it more exciting
to play because it felt like if someone
killed you with something that like it
wasn't just an unlockable thing you had
to get to level 25 to do you know what i
mean you actually had to go out and farm
it and finally get it my goodness like
yeah that was beautiful um but yeah to
continue um you know i had some life
stuff come up and i had to stop playing
destiny one uh probably i think before
trials came out or just as trials came
out right and or how's the wolves like
i would say
okay yeah it has been a very long time
since i've played um and there was a
giant gap and you know
life happens life stuff happens you kind
of fall out of certain feelings of
certain games and then when destiny 2
came out the beta specifically i played
it and as much as i really did like it i
was like this didn't really feel that
much different so i'm going to wait for
a little while before getting back into
the game because i was completely
addicted to battlefield 4 and warframe
battlefield battlefield east oh my
revolution oh the skyscraper
yes yes
i still can't believe like what they're
doing honestly with these current
battlefield games and not tapping back
into the absolute like magicalness of
battlefield 4 and the revolution being
able to flood an entire map by shooting
out the dam right and then changing the
fights from being on the ground into the
skyscrapers like what the f come on can
we get this again please it was bomb
blowing for its time i mean what the
mechanic became redundant after a while
but when you first did it and you see
how it dynamically changed the map it
was like this is pretty cool oh yeah no
it was it was amazing um
but yeah i got so into warframe as well
it was very grindy game but like oh
beautiful
um and then
stadia was announced from google
and
when i heard i i'm very big into tech i
i love technology i think technology is
is is crazy and when google was like hey
by the way we're going to come out with
a way to stream your games over the
cloud so any screen that you have as
long as you have a decent internet
connection to it you'll be able to play
games and i was like huh seems a little
bit too good to be true but i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna put my money forward
i'm gonna pre-order it and i'm gonna be
a founder for it because i really think
this is something that's really cool
that could happen and destiny 2 ended up
being one of the promotional attachments
to being a founder so if you were a
founder it came with destiny 2 and every
dlc that came up since then and destiny
2 at the time has been out for a while
and i think shadow keep was already out
there there was like two other dlcs or
one other dlc i think there was um and
so you know stata came out and i made my
account and i played the game on my like
tiny little macbook on wi-fi at my
college and everything and it worked
flawlessly there are issues yes for some
people if the internet is a little bit
weird and everything but it worked
flawlessly and i started playing destiny
2 and i was like oh my god this game
evolved so much since the beta and i'm
having a fantastic time with this
and it was the amount of people amount
of friends like good personal friends i
made on stadium because it was its own
um it was its own matchmaking you know
you had pc match making before cross
play you had ps4 he had ps um ps4 you
had xbox but then you also had stadia
and if you keep in mind steady at the
time on destiny 2 had like 9 000 players
i think it ever hit a max of like 20 000
players and then it just settled around
10 000. and that was it so you ran into
the same people over and over and over
and over but like you made friends
because of it you would literally go to
a public sec like a public location and
you'd run into somebody you saw
yesterday and you like actually be in a
in a voice chat like invite them and say
hey how's it going and then leave and
then like two days later you'd run into
the exact same person on like another
planet on a different public event and
everything and then you'd be like hey
how's it going and like you just talked
to each other and it was it was it
reminded me of like what destiny destiny
felt like originally because made a
family and that's actually how i started
my clan every single like reset on
tuesday we did um not voter class sorry
uh garden of salvation and everything
and um it was it was very sweet sweet
sweet experience
nice nice hey this this is classic man
this is oh man
so so much to get from this because
what's interesting to me before i'm
asking you is that you stepped away
from destiny but stadium brought you
back with the introduction of destiny 2
and then i remember that deal bungie
made the announcement they had you know
the the content packing it was a great
package like to to kind of launch this
service and uh
i remember that it was definitely
transformative and similar to you yes
i'm very
loved tech
even people that were scoffing at it i
said look the tech is actually good yeah
if you play it that it works it works
yeah
in general is like what
yeah no absolutely thousands of miles
away from like where the game is being
played and if your internet is you know
really good like you can legitimately i
i played stay down the woods on my phone
don't ask why i was in the woods i just
was and i was just playing on my bodies
yeah you know yeah do what you got to go
visit your family what you got to do
you go visit your uh your family out in
the woods where the rest of the bananas
are still hanging in the tree you know
so oh man oh yeah okay so we have to
obviously bring up the banana in the
room
because
i was gonna say elephant but i had to go
banana in the room
obviously like your twitter name your
profile your stadium time makes perfect
sense you play on stadia and you got
back into it for trials and
also the idea of like the trials
cheating and stuff like that how did
how did the banana become the persona
now it's not always a banana in a cup
maybe it's on the side of a screen
but
how
how did you choose where did the banana
persona come from and then what made you
stick with it have you ever thought
about changing it up like i got to know
the banana story now and we're actually
talking about the fruit guys
so like the banana stuff happened after
i ended up meeting fallout on stadia and
everything when they came over from the
from the uh cheaters on trials they
wanted to try steady out because you
couldn't cheat on there
and that's when i kind of got into
wanting to do streaming or try twitch
out right and at the time i was like
there are so many
people trying to stream on twitch so
many that if you just put up a webcam
you just have some fancy backgrounds you
might be really really fun to listen to
but i feel like having something that's
fun to watch as well was something that
sets you apart from all the other people
who are trying to start on that platform
you know everyone's mom and dad is is
trying to you know
try it out and you got to hit it off
somehow and i was like
how funny would it be
if i was
just a banana for some reason
and my roommates at the time when i told
them about that they're like do it
please do it it'll be so [ __ ] funny
sorry i swear then there but they were
like it's gonna be so funny and i'm like
you know what
okay yeah i'll give it a shot and i i
found a way to make this work and
everything and the first stream went in
and it went really really really well
and people came in they're like are you
a banana i'm like what
does it look like yes yes
and
the amount of
you know it keeps people there right you
know some people some people watch for
like the destiny
in the sky showing his gameplay sometime
in a little cup you know it's he's part
of the fun um and the cup actually ended
up happening uh you know that whole
trend on twitter the um
the hot tub streams
yes
yes yes so i initially tried doing that
with the banana and i was like all right
this isn't working out but i was like
you know what's funnier what if i
instead of a hot tub stream i did a hot
mug stream and so that is where the
coffee cup came from because i have like
like this little command on the stream
where you do it and me and my roommates
all recorded a bunch of like voice files
of us sipping coffee and everything and
some like little like there's like
percentages for certain ones to happen
like when we accidentally spilled it on
ourselves and we're going oh my god
and all this stuff and so people will do
that you'll hear a little
sip in the background whatever and i
just thought it was funny you know also
being able to like you know do this and
peek out every so often
you know
navigate and just have a good time you
know oh yeah
yeah you do with the banana like just
the
little wavy animations as you said you
can kind of pick yourself up and kind of
show them the
the tip of the banana somebody mentioned
like the spiderman kiss or something
which sounds
yeah uh we can do that at the end if you
want okay fair enough
oh that's that's great that's the after
darkness yeah that's that's the point
that's the post show you gotta subscribe
for that he can do that for you at the
end that was exclusive
well i mean he did invite me to the show
so you know it's it's only right that i
thought
yeah
stadium time is lit right man
i love it
this is too good so like
question was it yes or was the
this the initial iteration like did it
evolve into as far as like because right
now it's like super animated you got the
the fake shoe everything is just popping
right now so it's like my question is
was there like early stage where
or was it like this day one and then you
just been you know doing other things
around the the persona and everything
that you did going on from day one i i
made sure that my scenes kind of had
these little borders on them you know i
looked at a lot of uh twitch streams for
destiny and most of them just just has
the gameplay in the background and i was
like you know a border might take a
little bit away from the gameplay screen
but i think it just adds a little bit of
character to the stream so i had a
border on there i had a good little
talking screen where like it was up
close but i didn't have the mug at the
time i just had the you know little mic
i got here right
and i had the chat on the side and it
was pretty much
what you're seeing
without the mug um this is just a
specific scene that i made for uh for
discord when i'm streaming through obs
i'm using my using my stuff here um but
uh
i did evolve it a little bit over time
by adding mostly effects i think that's
one of the biggest benefits that i have
by doing this rather than just having my
camera is that i can have a random of
things that happen that like affect me
so if people in the chat spam the word
banana and there's like i think it's
three people within 15 seconds like this
gorilla comes out of nowhere and puts me
in a bag and then beats the hell out of
me
and it throws me back on the screen and
it's so good it's so funny when people
randomly get that to work it makes no
sense and and people love that right um
and then having another little
what else i was like i gotta know
besides the gorilla what else what are
these other crazy things that happen
uh well people are able to like change
the color well right now
they would have seen something they're
trying to get the banana triple going
right now make it happen it's funny
right now i probably have to interrupt
continue
no it's okay no it's okay um i well you
know like i kind of showed over here um
you know people can change the color of
the banana whatever they want you know
when they're feeling a little bit spicy
and they want a little bit of purple
they want a little bit of you know like
a blue right they want a little bit of a
green uh you know gives them the
opportunity to just to edit the things a
little bit more in that sense but
because it's me right i can move around
rather than just being a static color in
the background so you know it's just
another fun thing for people to be able
to do
and there's like a little disco effect
where when we got their trials tickets
this entire this disco ball would come
down from the top and then like these
the lights would start flashing in here
and everything and i just started like
[ __ ] dancing you know just having fun
and it was just funny
it was a good time um and then at some
point i was like you know what i want to
do
i want to do custom
transitions and stream start transitions
so what i ended up doing
was uh you know that thing in spongebob
where it was like the the the burger
really far back and the guy's like
introducing like duh duh duh duh duh duh
duh duh duh duh duh yeah yeah so i
changed it
so it's the it's the mug that slowly
starts to get bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger until it like fills up
the screen and then it's like
introducing and then swaps to the other
screen and it's just little things you
can do like with this that i just
thought makes the stream just so much
fun to be able to watch and then also
the anime transition i can probably show
you guys that a little bit later but oh
okay the anime transition
top notch
no doubt it's top notch
uh
i was gonna say and i was like are you
are we still in the banana are we going
back i was gonna go back to destiny is
that oh yeah no we can yeah we can go
back to destiny if you want to i mean i
don't care
i gotta follow up yeah
um no so i wanted to kind of ask you
obviously you've been to the lighthouse
many times you've helped people and
things like that that's kind of one of
those things that you enjoy doing but
the idea is
some of the stuff you do in trials is
if i went against you i would probably
just like quit trials for the day
sometimes because of the fact that you
do like hey it's triple glaives and
we're still going to go flawless to the
lighthouse and it's like
stuff like that that you've done and the
fact that you like maine bow which i
think only mercury's is the other one
who probably does that but like there's
not a lot there's a lot so are you like
intentionally anti-meta or just like
trying to find some of the weirdest
things and still make them work or
what's the intentionality behind your
kind of loadout choices that you do now
so in most games that i've played i pvp
games specifically i've always kind of
been
the the
like you said the anti-meta using things
that aren't normally used and i don't
know if that's like a weird pride thing
like oh man i hate getting killed by
this gun i'm never going to use this gun
right or i don't know if it's just like
a i want to be able to get so good with
this weapon that everyone kind of memes
on instead is not that great of a weapon
and then people go like holy crap is
this thing actually that good right and
so you know back in uh real quick and
like battlefield four do you remember
how the phantom bow in that game
yes you have to do so many convoluted
things to get a bow in like a game
that's supposed to be realistic shooting
and everything and it was the worst
weapon in the game and
i made it my number one weapon um
used and
it's just there's just something fun
about it and so when i additionally
heard destiny 2 had bows i was like yes
yes please i want to give it to me
and i i got a bose and i cannot wait to
talk about a certain bow and a certain
role on that bow that people really need
to get into because my goodness is she
is nasty
no no doubt yeah i was just
gonna ask you about like just in general
um one thing that really
caught my eye was uh
warlock love in a specific
subclass of warlock that i think i agree
with you that doesn't get the proper
respect
talk about that shade binder talk about
that stasis is the future throwing out a
couple of dural double turrets what's
the gloves names with the old omni
grassy i can't be pronounced
whatever
yeah yeah
you got it
like so tell me like that shade binder
man how did that start and uh your
appreciation for that class
well if i remember correctly shea butter
came out and at the time the melee was
admittingly um
disgusting
traveling so fast having an insane aoe
on the thing freezing for four seconds
we gotta have something we gotta
yeah um it was crazy it was insane it
was it was it was honestly insane um and
then they got a little bit of a tuning
and all of a sudden the shade binder
usage just
poof dropped gone you know and i barely
see it anymore and
i started i i like i said i i do trouse
carries at least i haven't been able to
do it lately because um college ended
and i came back home and now i'm looking
for a job i got a job actually and i got
to move by the end of the month so i
haven't been able to stream very much
anymore but i would always do trials
carries every friday and saturday i
started on stadia and when cosplay came
out i did it on pc xbox even a while on
stadium kind of as a little little hey
look stata might be made fun of but i
can still carry people even on pc right
so it's kind of like a you know it's
it's one of those things where you just
feel good when you manage to make it
work when people meme on the platform
you know um and i tried so many
different builds on all the characters
and the one character i kept on coming
back to the one subclass was constantly
shade binder and it's because of a
specific aspect that i swear to god
nobody uses which one i
frostballs froze false baby let's go
don't don't get close to me
it's a personal shotgun that guarantees
a kill baby and i cannot stress enough
how much people need to stop for a
moment wait a minute get on shadebinder
put on that aspect go to pvp and have a
gosh darn amazing time because you press
that rift button when you know someone's
pushing you real quick on that radar
yeah
you melee dead right you got the little
little tracking bolts that go after you
kill a frozen player grab another one
melee dead supers freeze them hit them
with something else with team shot melee
dead
it's such a great anti-sh anti-uh ape uh
yes
yes good point yeah
and for pushing actually um
i think the video i did with pattycakes
he has the clip in the background but
the way that i use frost pulse very
specifically is i use it as a
um
team wipe potential and by that i mean
if we get someone down and there's a
ghost and the ghost is just right there
and i know the enemy is about to revive
that ghost you know how you can do the
slide into your barricade or rift
so what i do is i stick around a corner
while crouch so i'm off the radar they
start that revive on the ghost and as
i'm sprinting towards them i slide and i
do the freeze and then when they revive
somebody they both get frozen and that
allows me to melee the person who got
revived shatter them and it instant
kills both of them and if all three
people are within three meters of each
other instant team wipe and there is a
clip on paddy's video that he did post
um i think two days ago or so if you
ever look at that uh interview with that
i did with him and it's it's it is
insane it is insane it really is and
people really need to put some time into
using it that's sick bro wow didn't you
know about that shout out to patty cake
got a voice salute that's crazy
i had to get my warlock love off for
that one because i see [ __ ] he shared
that
well
uh travis you got anything else for the
banana in a cup
or shall we see what's going on i i feel
like i'm just a viewer today i'm just
annoying
like
i was completely like
this is not normal you have transformed
he doesn't know how to
he doesn't watch he's always like you're
trying to get all of his words in and
you know into the head of travis is just
like what am i watching
yeah i'm literally just aghast at what's
happening i'm like
today i'm just a commenter
yeah no it's like before we get there i
wanted to ask
um
do you have a quick
quick couple of questions which raid
would you like to see in season 18 good
one good one
i would say
the one raid that i'm really excited for
now
i never got a chance to do what was the
siva based raid
oh yeah
i never did wrath i never did that i
would like to see wrath come back just
so i would get the experience of doing
wrath um but what i'm thinking about
them uh king's fall
with oryx
that raid
unlocked a part of me that i swear still
i still carry with me the whole campaign
the introduction of him
the raid opening where this giant titan
sized
winged creature flies out in space and
everything grabs the edge and he's like
you little [ __ ] so i'm gonna kill you
right i loved it i i i thought it was
amazing and and god my goodness i i it
was beautiful i i that's one i really
want to see back i would love to see
wrath just because i've never done it
before and i want to do it but honestly
all yeah king's fault please give me
give me here give enough now
do you have a top exotic weapon or two
currently that you that are like
favorites for you
oh
honey do i have a top exotic weapon and
that would be
ariana's vows
let me tell you about let me tell you
about uh stadium time this guy has
gotten more use out of his uh stream
deck than any person that has ever
purchased a stream deck let me tell you
dude this guy
is the best purchase he's ever made
without a doubt
it was a great investment yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
um clan is called banana bunch
oh that is the uh that is the discord
yeah so we have a little bit of discord
um i didn't make it until like months
into starting streaming because i was
like oh man i don't want to bother
people with like another discord but
after things got you know after we
managed to pass a thousand um followers
on on twitch and everything i was like
you know what okay let's make one and we
were coming out with a bunch of names
and we were like i love the banana bunch
i just think that's that's a really cute
thing for a community um and then we
have um times square like you know like
new york thing as like little um
the general chat for everyone you know
um so yeah banana bunch is kind of what
i like
my submission would have been uh the
banana republic
[Laughter]
that's pretty good too
yeah they have some pretty good banana
themed boxers actually i was gonna pick
up a pair i can't imagine why
[Laughter]
yeah i'd say those are both pretty solid
but yes to answer uh ibonta's question
uh ariana's vow has been my number one
exotic weapon in a very long for a very
long time um actually
since before beyond light and after
beyond light came out and the
shadebinder class came out there are
some interactions with ariana's val that
you can do with the melee that
unlock i feel like ariana's valve's
potential especially with the way that i
personally use it because i use a swap
build with those um and when you swap
from a bow to ariana's you're basically
getting max
range two shot bodies on the first hit
because death at first glance only
activates if you uh when you aim down
sights for that first body shot goes
away unless it's a headshot so there's a
lot of fun things you can do with it but
with shadebinder
a lot of people don't know at least i
haven't seen anyone else try this or
ever do this but the melee from shade
binder when it hits somebody it does 30
damage right
ariana's vow because it's a special
weapon it gets a 5 damage buff on frozen
targets and when you have death at first
glance active and you're aiming down
sight it buffs the damage on a frozen
target to 176. so guarantee if you hit
someone yep so if you hit someone with
that freeze melee and they're frozen
they can't go anywhere you hit them once
in the head they shatter they're dead
transfers over to the next person from
the little little crystals that like
look for another player and you get
another free kill and i use that for
very frequently predicting when people
are running around the corner or or
corner peaks for where snipers are or
especially like i said earlier with the
frost pulse and the ghosts there's a
ghost that's about to be revived i wait
till i hear that little pinging sound i
toss that melee freeze both of them and
then we just team shot and they're dead
instantly it's such a good team shot
class especially
a 1v3 class because of frost pulse
because people normally in a 1v3 those
three people like there's one person
just rush them you know just just go for
it just go for it quick not honey not if
i got a frost pulse because i hide
around the wall i time it i watch that
radar throw it down freeze two people
melee shatter them the third one
boom headshot dead easy
and i love it and i love it quite a bit
that's fire that's fine like i think it
as a great defensive maneuver defensive
and offensive actually offensive is the
biggest thing like people think frost
pulse okay just use it as a stationary
they're gonna come to you no you go to
them no no you go to them you know
they're behind that corner baby you just
do a slide rift into a freeze you freeze
them blind
that's it they're done you know
fire fire travis i'm assuming
like one last slide shot as a part of
your builds and that was it i was gonna
ask that class
question
slide shot as a as a perk is that
something that you kind of synergize
with it no
okay i'm just curious continue travis
since we do have a show we have a uh we
have a long running segment
um and the segment is called let's help
ibontus
um it is for the people who play destiny
who
have a um
less than savory
kda in the crucible and are looking to
get good if you will um and so we have
people who are pvp mains come on the
show and give us their top
tip for getting good at crucible and uh
who better
than to give uh give a tip than someone
with so much appeal
god i can't love you enough
you know i mean he just he separates
himself from the bunch you know what i
mean guys
it's really important
so you know before you have to split
you're going to make him out of you
you're going to make him blush over here
he's going to turn different colors on
us again
i mean you keep on complimenting me too
much i'm going to have to steal you yeah
so if he uh
he's got a pirate hat if he if he i'm
gonna plunder that booty
noise
if he wanted to uh get good at crucible
um
what
would uh he have to do what what would
you
could you draw him up a plan tane you
see the lovely thing i find about
destiny is pve is your pvp trainer
simple as that right i mean if you have
friends who can give the time to be able
to go into a private lobby and
and practice a few things i'll get into
what people really should practice but
pve is just an absolutely lovely way to
be able to go in there and relax but
specifically aim to train for pvp in
that sense you always aim for head shots
you look at where your positioning is
you're gonna look like an [ __ ]
running lake of shadows like you're
doing trials round seven but but when
you get into trials round seven you're
gonna know a little bit more about where
you are in your surroundings if that
makes sense and so i always say like if
someone wants to start out in pvp uh
let's be honest destiny can be a it
might be very forgiving in a sense with
like the aim assist and the bullet
magnetism but because everybody has that
when the really good players have that
too they're really really good players
and so when a new player tries to start
pvp and they're just getting absolutely
like mowed down by all these players
they need a safe place that they can go
into where they can practice which is
why i'm happy that des bungie did say
something about implementing a soft
skill based matchmaking because it does
allow those players to only match
against newer players initially until
they get a little bit better at a time
and be able to to handle those
situations but i always say yeah just do
a bunch of strikes right do your quest
stuff but then do a bunch of strikes and
treat those strikes those pve matches
like their pvp and and don't go for just
i'm just going to kill this thing real
quickly with body shots like very
specifically you want to get good with a
sniper only aim for headshots only going
for headshots because that'll train it
it'll like you'll build that muscle
memory to be able to aim for that zone
that you need that crit at and i know
pve hitboxes are different from pvp but
it's a very nice casual way to just
practice your aim throughout the day
without having that that struggling
suffocating feeling of like my goodness
like i'm doing terrible i'm getting
killed constantly my team's getting
killed constantly they're probably angry
at me and it's a nice place and you know
as you get better you go into control
and one of the biggest things people
really
i feel like mess around with is is their
positioning where they are on the map
right corners are seriously your best
friend having a side to be able to dip
back into when you're caught in a bad
location is is
very important to know where you are on
the map you don't even know you know the
map you just need to know i'm next to a
wall i'm not in the middle in the
opening right and so if someone pops up
out of nowhere and i'm failing this
fight i can just back out around it and
and recover a little bit wait for a
teammate i find a lot of new players
just gung-ho and just stand still in
like an open spot right or or don't
understand really where they're going
and don't go with their team
so yeah you really do need to understand
like positioning most of all gun play
will come as it goes right you get
better with aiming just by playing the
game and that's the nice thing about pve
is it trains your aim at most of all
but pvp you really got to know your
positioning and so it's kind of like a
little dance it's a little tango you got
to do along the way by taking care of
both things but mostly that positioning
your aim will will develop the more you
play right
if that helps at all yeah no always like
to hear
it's kind of always interesting to hear
everybody's always got a different take
or slightly different variation or just
you know kind of the main
main way to help a beginner in the world
of pvp i always appreciate the way it's
usually phrased
by the pvp gurus and they all tend to
come out well yours was no different you
absolutely nailed it so
i like
like what i'm hearing there
well i think that has been a hilarious
introduction to our banana in a cup
and we do actually have some current
stuff going on in the world of destiny
this is the last week of solstice
i did want to check and see if
anyone in this podcast has done much
solstice check the boxes or
not
hey i got a thumbs up from travis what
about you kyle i got i got my my uh seal
man
oh
nice wow oh you're the seal i'm
impressed yeah
i did it they call me seal team six
because i'm so
i have that seal um yeah i i didn't much
like the event uh but it was nice junk
food after in between reviews so i just
spent like you know a couple hours a
couple nights just getting through it
and uh yeah it's a
you know
like
we've talked about it a million times
about how they need to clean up the
event but i did do it which i it makes
me feel like i'm uh
my bona fides are back i was feeling
pretty bad there a month not playing
destiny because of the anime review so
good times
yeah so casually in there you know
getting the little bonfires getting my
ass shout out to dj he was in there with
me he's trying to play catch up so it's
funny is teaching someone the mechanic
and you're like all right so we got to
go in there
they're gonna get this thing and then
you're gonna fit this kindling thing and
then you're gonna put the kidney thing
in the thing and then you're gonna imbue
it and then you're just gonna change the
stats and then just seeing him with the
loop and then just remember
you gotta play other stuff to get the
leaves
don't go in there without the league and
the funny the game tell me like don't go
in here without you ain't got no leaves
so i think i think it's funny does it
tell you if you try and start it you
don't have to leave
by the way
you ain't got enough currency to be in
here so i thought that was of amazing
you're just you're just doing volunteer
work in here you know
yeah yeah yeah
it was aggressively not worth it as how
i would describe getting the seal and
the armor also
not really worth it i didn't really get
any armor that i couldn't have gotten
from zurr you know every week just
buying that so yeah
yeah for me it was just about the glow
because i was like all right
literally i was like because this you
know i'm doing drastically now so i'm
like all right arc 3.0 is coming i got
my insidious i've got looking at my
bills i'm going to rock so i said okay
let me put a find a nice little i found
this fire shader for for the new um the
solstice gear okay like a dark huish
blue very icy i'm warlock's ready and i
got my own crowd of tempest ready to go
and i got my other a little outfit
what's that um
the the one that the the storm trance
that when you use it and you get kills
it gets stronger and stronger and
stronger and then if you you uh kill a
lot of enemies with it you have like
half of your super and stuff like that
it's a great extra storm caller is
something i forget it's a great razor's
trance or something
yeah yep storm brace i love that it's
highly underrated so i've been using
those two i'm just getting my synergy so
literally i'm in solstice to look good
to get the gear that i want
and and put the flames on it and i was
like i'm good now i'm outside so that's
what i did but yeah to to travis's point
it was yeah i was like i don't think i'm
doing that seriously
and you know what it was too that
incentivized me was
i usually like the solstice shirt and i
was like this [ __ ] the bright orange one
like i don't know if this skin tone and
bright orange is working
out like tangerine on this right here
like
dj just said it look good because he has
he's committed because he's got every
other social structure
he knows he doesn't look good because
he's a dusty white guy with no style
taste that's his problem
oh yeah no it's like i joke i haven't
showed i even showed the shirt to my
wife and i was like i don't really know
if that works and i was like i could get
the tank top she's like do it
you're going to the tank top
fall off right off of me
you don't have shoulders
i don't have an opinion hey we got we
got our serving of fruit here we need a
serving of beef too
i'll get my spaghetti strap tank top on
and get booted off off stream or
something in here as well
cut off baby let's go sun's out gun's
out
yeah
you would have been drifting for me a
large i go for it
[Laughter]
yeah i'm not ordering the shirt either
um
but yeah the thing that the thing that i
saw because i saw
scaro tweet about this is this week the
final week
they fix the double and triple
progression for your alternate
characters
this is like the we this is the weirdest
timing unfortunately because if it would
have been in the second week like week
two
you know more people would probably have
been like okay i went to but if you get
two weeks into the event people like all
right i'm gonna either grind it out and
it's just gonna suck or i'm just not
gonna do it now it's like kind of too
little too late but also slap into the
face of the people who did it it's this
weird timing thing so i wasn't excited
to see that that was supposed to be a
thing and then now it's two weeks into
the event so in the final week you get
the bonus progression
i don't know just but they didn't also
say it was coming so i don't know if it
was like they didn't know if they were
gonna get it fixed or not so it just was
yeah the weird
i mean i just didn't love and it's
either like or if people were like on
the fence do you really think they're
gonna come back in the final week i
don't know
it was just a little strange but yeah
that seems to be a little characters too
like why would you
what's the point of that i think i mean
if you want to go for the glows for the
other characters that's literally it
yeah
i mean i think we can all three of us
four of us what am i talking about all
four of us agree yeah i was looking at
you guys
so beautiful three people in a banana
yeah you know what okay yeah all three
of us um
can all agree that the main thing that's
really shutting down these events is how
convoluted it doesn't have to be
right when try and smog first came out
you had to farm to get this and then
turn this into that and then buy this
and then turn that into that and then
turn this into that so you can get that
and it's like why why do you have to do
all this stuff like and then they
finally changed it where they're like
okay you just get this one quest you do
what you need to do and you turn the
damn thing in you get your gosh darn
armor all right i want to look fancy and
then this mode comes out and they're
like okay you got to do other missions
to get this and then do this mission to
get that and i'm like why couldn't you
have just made it so the amount of dunks
you make grant you the thing you have to
do the other missions for and then at
the end of the exact same mission they
automatically get turned into whatever
it is right you earn both things from
the same exact objective and now there's
no oh [ __ ] and i gotta do like 50 more
more strikes right there's just
focus on that one mission get everything
done quickly right it's not even gonna
it's like it's gonna be super fast right
it's still gonna take time to do but it
makes it more streamlined and more
approachable instead of wondering oh
[ __ ] i just realized i did this mission
five times in a row and i didn't have
the goddamn thing
yeah
yeah yeah i was like for me i'm i'm in
the same boat as
it's this weird balance of if i just did
the bonfire bash over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over
and that was the way you did the event
that would also get to be tiring but on
the other side
every single solstice event that we get
to
just exacerbates how stale the other
playlists are like okay so what's the
best way to do it probably go on strikes
and it's like and it was like nightfalls
actually seemed to be a good balance and
then it got to be
something i was oh and then wellspring
for certain one of the challenges was
pretty good but there's certain you
figure out what the couple are and then
you're like okay now i'm just doing the
other thing multiple times but when they
throw you in strikes no one wants to
play gambit
crucible's there but it's like the
strike playlist that got so stripped
down after the dcv
every time they throw us back in there
you're reminded like i feel like i've
run this strike like three times and
then you somehow there's not even that
many strikes but there's enough but yet
the
you play the same like two or three over
and over and over it's just this weird
repetition when they take you into the
basic playlists and that's i guess one
of the things that again i could hope
for a light fall for some kind of
rejuvenation there it's like they have
nightmare hunts they have psyops
battlegrounds um which could go into
there they already put the regular
battlegrounds in there i'm just like if
you want to push us into the vanguard
ops playlist for lots of things
put it all in there i was like
so i'm just hoping at some point that
gets a little bit better but no i'm with
you guys too it's it's them it's i know
they're trying to
probably help engagement and be like hey
if we make you guys go to other
playlists later in the season there's
going to be more people in the playlist
for everybody but then you're reminded
of why you don't really want to go in
the playlists and then you go in and
then you realize how stadia said it
could just be very simple you go in
there however many you dunk
that's how much dust you get and you're
out and it's like why is that so
difficult it's not and that's the
problem is it could be very simple and
every time we get something it's
frustratingly convoluted and i guess
we'll see how it goes next season but
there can't be any way that the people
who are developing it with they're doing
a fantastic job they're probably doing
what they're being told to do you know
they almost guaranteed know that
everyone's like guys like this is a
little bit too much
like
one two steps fine three four steps
pushing a little bit you know what i
mean and and so you know it it sucks
because then they're the ones that take
the brunt of it because everyone's like
what are these developers doing they're
so blah blah blah and it's like like
you know you do have to cut them some
slack because again it's not like
they're the ones that can just be like
guys we need to stop this you know they
have higher ups that tell them different
things but it does sometimes make you
wonder a little bit like at what point
are they going to realize that proper
little
um how much time and effort actually
needs to go into these things that
people will want to come back because
i'll be honest the most fun that i've
had with this entire event was
dreamworks bug being able to overload
certain weapons um i don't know if you
saw the uh the 10 000
um round sweet business video that i put
on my
twitter yeah yeah yeah
so much fun i had an absolute blast with
that and that wasn't even the event and
so when that got patched i'll be honest
i just stopped playing the event i'd
finished my warlock i don't know i i was
just going to buy
with bright dust the armor set for the
the titan and the hunter and just called
it call at a time yeah i've been i've
been playing other games at the moment
um just waiting for the season kind of
just because the campaign for the season
for season of the haunted
beautiful
smexy all right fantastic they did a
great job with the actual missions and
like the story and feeling for kaidel
and zavala
and and eris and everyone really
understanding where their headspace is
and how you know everything is kind of
piecing together with kallus they did a
great job with that but once that was
over
mm-hmm
it's like
[Music]
bye and yeah everything else right like
i yeah yeah it feels a little bit like
that and you know
i'm sure that i'm sure it's gonna pick
up next season i'm sure there's going to
be something that's going to bring us in
for for quite a long time you know
they're introducing a different game
mode i think next season right yep
recruiting
yeah we'll get to the other thing but
yeah
yeah so that's actually a perfect lead
into the iron banner 4-1-1 for season
18. so iron banner will not be rift next
season i know some people will be happy
some people will be sad rift is not
totally gone though we'll get to that
here in just a little bit
uh but basically they said the core
vision started as a conversation like
what if
when you went on kill streaks saladin
shouted he's on fire or
uh he shouted boom shakalaka and all the
chaotic chaos went from there and then
they said eruption was born
so what is eruption this is what iron
banner is going to be in season 18.
uh eruption is clash
with energy boost based on killstreaks
so it was affectionately called streak
mayhem internally before we gave it a
real name during eruption killing your
opponent scores one point
and a normal amount of energy after that
when you get a second elimination in a
row so we're literally getting to like
call of duty kill streaks
uh you start lightly glowing this is
after this is like kill number two
uh you start generating 10 super or you
start kills start generating 10 super
and 20 for all your abilities so
theoretically if you get six kills
you're probably going to refill your
abilities and then
half of your super and your score is
three points per kill instead of one so
it's going to be huge for streaks when
you get your fifth kill without dying
you become primed the previous stage was
surging sorry uh you are you begin
glowing brightly your team goes on the
hunt which you kind of don't do in other
modes everyone on the team gains five
percent super and 10 grenade melee and
class energy
you gain
twelve percent super and five percent
grenade melee and class energy per kill
if you keep going after five
and you get three points per kill sounds
great who wouldn't want to be primed
well you have a 15 second cooldown timer
if the timer reaches zero you erupt
which kills you and resets your streaks
so if you don't get another if you get
to five
and then don't get another kill you
erupt so they're definitely forcing that
person to be aggressive stadia will be
totally fine since he just loves the
push
uh you are then also marked for both
teams so everyone can see right where
you are
the other team gets three points for
killing you
and then more than one player can be
primed at a time
so they're excited to get eruption in
everyone's hands we hope it continues to
illustrate our desire to bring new and
unique experiences to crucible
um and they said well so and then i
think it's gonna be for
three weeks they mentioned it somewhere
there's three iron banners next season
uh oh yep there you go that's it as well
yeah so week one eight and fourteen
so yep while rift won't be an iron
banner next season it will be in a
weekly rotator so okay so that's just
that's the rift piece sorry
uh yeah so iron banner will be it sounds
like
it will be this eruption event next week
or next season so i wanted to see what
you guys think about
the streaks the benefits the takeaways
kind of where are we at and uh
banana i think you get to go first i
know travis is excited
it's it's different and i like that you
know it's kind of like like i said
initially like they're kind of like a
mayhem but you have to do something in
order to get those super abilities and
your abilities back faster um i enjoy
that because it kind of it reminds me of
almost um like black ops one kill
streaks yeah you know you get those
kills and you get that nice little uav
right you put that up in the air and
then you'll be able to push you get that
little machine gun you put a little
corner yeah it is online oh yeah about a
little rc xd right yes i think it was
black ops 2. um but yeah no it kind of
reminds me of that you're kind of yes
the players that are you know at the
maybe more experienced level are the
ones that are mostly going to benefit
from these things um but regardless it's
still something that anyone can achieve
because it comes with assists it's not
just kills it's from assists as well um
and i i think it's gonna be fun that
worry on the back of your head of oh my
god i only have 15 seconds before i die
and you gotta like go go go go go to
find like somebody else to be able to
survive i think that's going to be a fun
little rush i think that's going to be
fun rush
travis
i don't even really care if the mode is
good or not i'm just glad that they're
trying new things
honestly
they needed to try new things for so
long and actually this makes me
super happy that i did not do the iron
lord uh
uh seal this this is getting to do it
doing okay okay now i get to do it
during a new mode that that isn't busted
as as all hell so
um yeah i played a little bit of iron
banner you know with rift and
didn't really like some of the changes
they made but i do like riff generally
but it didn't kind of stick with me so
i'm excited to push through on this mode
and get get iron lord next season but um
yeah i'm just i'm super stoked about
this man like they should try new stuff
honestly my one concern about this is
that it's too mild i like that they're
doing some stuff but it's sort of just
like you know a tweak on a mode and i
kind of want them to just go crazy and
try like completely new stuff and just
be goofy uh
but um you know that's just my
pessimistic brain that's saying it's
never gonna be competitive so might as
well make it silly um but yeah i uh i i
am
i'm very excited to try this i am and i
and i'm going to reserve judgment on
whether it's fun or good or anything
like that until after i've had a chance
to play it but in the meantime i'm just
letting myself be excited that there's
finally going to be a new game mode and
destiny it's been way too long
yeah i do think it's a little bit of a
shame though that it's only going to be
three times in a season right i do wish
they would kind of do like a crucible
labs
and made this a crucible labs mode right
and have some fun and maybe every week
they get a chance to change it up
slightly like okay instead of 15 seconds
you got 10 seconds maybe maybe you got
20 seconds right maybe you get way more
points you're way more super for getting
kills while you're while during that 15
second period you have before you die
there's you know there i feel like they
would have had more of an opportunity to
really just have fun with it and let the
pvp team play with those percentages if
they just made it a persisting mode that
you can play maybe every other week
rather than all right i'll see you guys
in like a month
i don't know i guess i guess that's the
way i see it with it i love it i do like
the difference but
they mention that too and they say um
one of the things we learned with rift
in this current season is if we have a
brand new mode like the most recent
iteration of rift introducing it to
everyone in a high focus environment
first highlights interval issues that
any multiplayer game has instead we are
going to be moving forward with the zone
control plan
introducing it as a as low pressure
crucible labs
first to make sure it performs as
intended in a real world setting then
and only then do we bring the new iron
banner or the new mode to iron banner
albeit with unique twist uh we
definitely need
uh we will definitely come back to
control and rift for iron banner in the
future but expect a familiar mode with a
unique experience
in season 19. in the meantime they talk
about rift so it sounds like they want
to do that testing crucible labs but it
also sounds like
this is going to be
four season 18's iron banner so
literally
it seems like they kind of contradicted
themselves like here's this new thing
we're gonna do but we're also gonna do
it nine banner in the big popular thing
when you see it two or three times in
the season
it was like unless i read that wrong it
does seem like this will be an iron
banner so we're gonna
experiment on it again and they'll take
feedback and do the changes so
in the future it sounds like they'll do
the crucible labs thing but i guess this
one is still going to be uh coming in
maybe a bit hot seems like kind of the
way rift was
you know we've got more pvp
info in the past few weeks let me have
in a while yeah right so that's a nice
thing at least you know yeah super
excited uh i was pleasantly surprised to
read this this
really excited me and yeah it's do
something new let's get creative you
know this side of the house we've
already talked that nauseam every last
word about how the pvp love is not there
i'm excited it's i like the individual
aspect to it i like that multiple people
can be primed and do the eruption thing
at the same time
um the the mechanic of of being what is
it the final stage of it with that 15
seconds
yeah and what i like is it it does
promote a bit of aggressive gameplay but
you know it it's it's to be fun you know
see i i think i think it's a lot of
potential especially the ability
um recharge rates and stuff like that i
think that's really cool you know just
to see that little spin on it i'm all
for it man bungie to me when it comes to
you know first person shooting gun gun
play you know they're just superior to
everyone else so
they started these cool modes in a halo
and things like that let's get back to
the roots let's get back to these
creative modes i'm still gonna die on my
hill where's my exotic gun game you guys
got the best
that's going to be like not not saying
the easiest but i'm like that is primed
to be a thing there are 60 70 exotics
however many there are
you can work through you know you need
to get it's like a rumble match you need
to get 25 kills but everybody's like you
get a kill use a different exotic it's
like and you know you're going to have
some lulls and people catch up when
you're trying to use a sword against
machine guns and stuff's going to go
crazy but
that's that's part of the fun of those
things and the final kill was a knife it
always had to be so a final kill could
be a sword like same principle
i look at fiesta from halo i look at
that type of stuff and i think
to me where it even helps them is that
they have so much weapons you know
their time made a good point about like
he does things that i like i do as far
as like
using things that are off better right
and then you find usage for it and
you're like wow this is really effective
it's just that everyone is going for
this other thing based on the
percentages or whatever but like imagine
starting off with i don't know i'm just
making a rat king or whatever something
that's not utilized right now in the
current meta and everyone's forced to
start with that as a baseline you'd be
surprised sometimes you get better
with said weapon you're like wait a
minute this is actually not that bad
sometimes it is bungie has a way of
making you do your homework but then
when you do it you're like you know what
remember you were mountain top
on mountain top and now like breach
loads i enjoy even though everybody
hates when breach loads come at them but
i enjoy using breech loads because i
went through mountaintop quest for real
and now i'm actually i'm not like the
best at using them but i feel like i'm
okay when i finally like commit to it
for a little while no i totally get that
but i mean you could start with like rat
king and then throw them into sweet
business you've got a bunch of miniguns
and then everybody has graviton lance
and then you're over here like everybody
gets you know
i don't i don't know
i think fight line like somebody we
start fighting
there you go exactly
you gotta level up all right cool now we
get soros now we get this like it the
potential is so there and it could be so
much fun if they implement this stuff
yeah i was like and that's one of those
things the only thing i wonder there is
how they do
it's something where they're like have
to override your character's unlocked
exotics the way they kind of do a scorch
cannon where it's like the gun is in
your hand in this match but it's like
when you leave obviously it's not there
right you'll have ownership yeah you
don't have ownership because that might
have that yeah so that's like there's an
issue with like the way the the the
game engine is set up where yeah it just
does not allow that whatsoever and they
have to think of some like a really
creative way to like make it work yep
that's a good part and that's that's
exactly like what what behind the scenes
thing is stopping that because it feels
like
we can't be the only ones who thought of
that there's however many exotics we
talked about but for them is it some
weird character history thing like if
i've ever held it now i can just pull it
from collections like what does it do
now granted on the other side of that
even if it wasn't an issue
what if like
you know after a certain point you know
the game unlocks if you play a certain
amount of this mode unlocks after a
little while you got to kind of play for
a while unlock some stuff
they do all the oldest exotics with this
thing
the you know are not quite as cool or
some have been like made up or whatever
it's like i feel like yeah which exotics
are paid which are not it's like yeah
that gets probably a little weird
but i it's something i hope they could
make work because as you said it's
primed for it because of the variety of
weapons they have
well i'd love to i'd love to see that
enough
what other i mean is there would you
guys like to see like a king of the hill
or
what other modes would you guys like to
see
them try because they mentioned in
season 19
um you know be a familiar mode but with
unique experience but i mean season 20
season 21 when hopefully we see maybe a
new map every so often excuse me or
maybe a mode in the next year
what would you guys like to see added to
the game outside of our little exotic
experiment
well two modes that i've been actually
one mode is not in the game one mode
i've kind of been doing in a private
lobby which is actually a lot of fun um
remember search and destroy oh
yes i really enjoyed search and destroy
and so sometimes i'm wondering what if
they had a version like that where there
was just a giant payload in the game two
of them or something and then you know
it's a 3v3 maybe a 4v4 who knows and
then you know like it's like black ops
you pick up the bomb you drop off one
location now you get to protect it and
someone stands inside the zone maybe
instead of having to like interact with
it if the enemy stands inside that zone
kind of like defusing the mines um in
the in the warden uh
uh strike then then it cancels but then
people if they're inside them it stops
it you have to fight each other i'm sure
there's some kind of play that you could
do with that um but i've actually been
having a lot of fun um with like an
infected type game mode where we'll go
into a private lobby and then you'll
have um the way we did it was uh six six
hunters and then one hunter on the enemy
team and that person had to have their
hud off and the only way they could kill
someone was by killing with the melee
and so everyone else was trying to hide
and keep away from them or like defend a
little bit and when that person got that
kill it would swap you would have to
swap from that team onto the other um
the seeking team turn off your hud and
now you can only use the melees and we
kept on doing that until there's only
one person left and it makes it it makes
it a lot of fun a lot of fun and i
definitely think destiny could get away
with the game mode like that because
that is one that i had a lot of fun with
in call of duty you know it's not a
problem borrowing game modes from other
games because if they're successful
they're gonna you're gonna be able to do
it in a special way that just makes it
interesting you know
yeah david and chat literally just asked
about what you described so there's two
people already thinking that i mean yeah
the whole you already have two different
teams you could like when you die then
you spawn on the other side you know
drop the hud something like that that'd
be kind of cool
travis you got any game modes from
previous experience that you'd like to
see
i still would like to see them mess
around with non-2v2 teams or
free-for-all like i want to see 3v3 or
4v4 teams i think would be cool
there's lots of ways you can make that
super fun and interesting
the other way is
i would really like i feel like destiny
is super primed for
like um
juggernaut
you know what i mean like a mode where
you know one whoever kills the
juggernaut becomes him because we
already have kind of like a super mode
in destiny which is your you using your
super and so if you could choose like a
roaming super and then you just have
infinite super until somebody kills you
and then whoever kills you gets their
super
like however however long you hold your
super is kind of like your times that
would be like the score yeah exactly
you you win by by
by being the juggernaut the longest i've
always thought like destiny is a little
perfect for that because it already has
like a magical super powered form
um so i've always thought that would be
useful have you guys played i'm assuming
you have um call of duty infinite i
think was infinite warfare they had a
game mode where it was like a basketball
almost where you had to pass the ball
and bring it to the enemy side and then
dunk it inside like you to toss it
inside of the goal you know how in the
current or i think last week's um
sorry nightfall uh the corrupted yep you
pick up the ball and you have to throw
it to a teammate imagine a game mode
like that where you have to pick up the
ball almost kind of like a rift but you
go into third person and you have like
10 seconds before you explode if you're
holding it so you have to toss it to a
teammate
basketball potato yeah almost like hot
potato and you have to bring it to like
the enemy side and then toss it into
their goal and someone can jump out and
intercept it from the enemy team right
and then he goes now you get the goal i
i think that could that could have a lot
of potential too i think
and they've kind of had that's what they
they if even though i cannot
stand that raid aspire star they kind of
had that mechanic throughout the whole
raid where you could kind of throw the
football and get the greed off of you
remember that that was part of a little
fun with even though they made you do it
the whole raid but a boat would be cool
i i think that you ever do spire star
i probably wouldn't right
i think i think i think it did it once
actually before it got to it it got uh
thrown into the vault
but yeah
too many jokes like in everything i say
is just like sad banana and everything
else just like
i'm just like i can't not it's just
yeah it happens all the time with the
banana bunch i'm sure but that's yeah
when you when you get a chance to do
this right
exactly
save the moment uh good at me baby i can
take it
no but i mean somebody mentioned capture
the flag i still would be curious
because
i know rift has it in the middle and
then you like you pick it up and you
push but if you have one on either side
you have farther to travel and then you
also can bring it back and it's
simultaneous working we have sixes so
there's enough people i still would be
curious if they would just do
a legit capture the flag i know rift is
probably like their middle ground
because they have to have to make their
own but i mean as you said travis it's
like you don't have to reinvent the
wheel all the time some of these are
just like pre-made things that you can
just like bring into your game
and again same thing like eruption is
probably like a variation on something
else out there but they always have to
put their own spin
sometimes yeah just get some more stuff
in there
would be fun
don't even get me started on sparrow
racing though that's that's that's nice
oh don't get me started i know
you're gonna help me i never got a
chance to experience sparrow racing and
i i i feel bad
i wake up in a cold sweat every single
morning and i just think
uh sparrow racing leader i could have
experienced it and and i failed
have you ever eaten a banana on stream
that's like canada
actually if you didn't i think i'm
allergic to bananas actually wait really
is this a real thing listen the last
time i've had a banana it was back in
like kindergarten and i was eating it
for like i don't know breakfast or lunch
or whatever and like
i felt my throat get like closed up
almost and i started choking and then i
and then i spit it out but then i did it
again and then i think that like scared
me ever since then like
on that or something for me
i've i've gotten tested honey and i
always say i'm fine so it's like what
the [ __ ] knows and so it's like you know
ever since then i just don't like the
taste of bananas you know i mean i take
a banana smoothie honey but like regular
bananas nah no thank you you know that's
i think this persona is good enough when
it comes to that
he is one with the banana but he will
not eat a banana yeah i i lead those to
what i cannot have almost
uh shout out real quick to the super
chat mri gamer again thank you for the
other one as well it was just previously
just a banana super chat this one is to
support the channel and because you
brought us a man banana you you are
welcome that's that's what we do here
yes um yeah i just i hope
it is
it's one of these things when i sit here
and think about it in my head of like
hey i hope we get we just listed off
like six different game modes
the pace that some of these tend to be
coming out the time they take to test
them and then kind of work through some
of the bugs and then get them in our
hands
we only have about two years left of
this saga we don't have a clue obviously
what happens after that
some type of continuation they've said
destiny 2 will live on or whatever but
it is still weird to kind of have that
finite nature and be like
you still wonder it's like how much
effort are they going to put in
when there is this you know possible
two-year window on it's like do we
really try and figure out this crazy
exotic gun game with this weird code
we're going to have to make
if it's only going to last for x number
of times because after the saga i have
to imagine revolts have to get blown up
again at some point that's going to
happen there's no way
there is no way
they have okay they got rid of sun
setting
which should have probably stayed around
and then you're telling me if they do
like a next saga that i just get to
carry my 7 000 weapons from the past
years in
e don't be silly
okay
they don't blow up vaults anymore they
put things in vaults is anybody else
your weapons will get vaulted
very different okay what'd you what'd
you say
don't worry about it did you say your
vault did you say you're vault's full
no
just keep talking ignore me
that was classic
yeah mine is all the time don't worry i
live out of my postmaster even at 600
because i'm awful so yeah i got to clean
it up before the next season i'm awful i
know i'm aware
i get crap about it all the time i fully
have accepted my problem i get it
this is not even this is that like
i would i would travel like we've
already experiencing
the sun setting right now like to me
i've already seen it it's it's it's all
you have plug one but you don't got plug
one with the origin tray
oh no yeah the original trades are like
uh yeah two point five yeah they just
soft stuff
yeah they have to do that with armor at
some point because right now especially
with like
what they're doing is you know they're
giving you a chance to really roll into
your specs like and if you get a 66 a 67
or a 68 that has the stats about where
you want them
you're not really i was trying to skip
that one hey
sorry
[Music]
it would continue
but yeah it's like that's kind of thing
at some point they have to do like an
armor 3.0 a 2.4 whatever because
too many people are gonna have sets of
armor that at that point you're just
like okay what do i need switch mods
i still hope that's the thing in
lightfall because we have had armor be
pretty stagnant for quite a long time so
i'm hoping that's a thing
yeah and then i look at something like
so i love when you're like hold on what
are you doing to
what do you what are you doing my my
vault
you're over here saying it's basically
happening anyway that's a big banana
i had to say it i had to say it
somebody's got to do it yeah yeah it was
it was fake it was the thing
[Laughter]
he doesn't have to be on he's just like
i'm just in chat today
travis if you are ever like busy i'm
just going to call stadia to fill in for
you and we're good
yeah
that's it
bananas are the ties of food
i don't know it makes sense to me
i mean they're they're wearing their
suits you gotta you gotta undress them a
little bit every time
well i'm already pretty unzipped
you just like look at me i'm already
like you know oh [ __ ] i gotta go to this
one
you know it's not that much more you
gotta really do
it's just like
it's just a little bit more i love how
there's this like slight accordion thing
that like the physics of the banana
ketchup
[Laughter]
yeah if you guys didn't watch the video
for this show you are missing out on
some gold
anyway literally gold
no okay
yeah all i was gonna say was just the um
and also look at when you look at
something like avarice armor
right yeah you know again it's still in
two dimensions
yes so i'll send that because you want
that as the pristine armor and then once
you get it your old stuff you're looking
at it like ah you know got that extra
slot so
and i already mastered this
it's slowly
pushing us into removing stuff from the
vault if they ever give us armor with
even one more energy everything is no
like everything is useless
yeah i want that one more energy because
you know they always are like hey here's
an extra slot but now you get to just
spread that butter a little thinner on
the toast than you did before as opposed
to here's an extra slot
the the mods from the artifact still
cost something so i can't have one extra
energy for that extra mod no okay i
don't know
i don't know if they have to do power
creep to make you get to convince you to
get rid of your armor i think all they
have to do
is roll out an armor 3.0 which doesn't
even have to be stronger they just have
to not automatically upgrade your armor
2.0 stuff and you'll switch on your own
because that's what they do in the past
right they just redesign the system and
then they go well the system you're on
is antiquated and then you go all right
fine i'll get rid of all my stuff and
they they sort of convince you to delete
your own crap that's what they did with
weapons yeah do you know how many people
who have farmed exotics that are going
to be really holding onto those things
for a while though oh yeah i feel like i
got my perfect lauralee splendor and
then all of a sudden you're like you did
what to armor
not mine back to the last sector
i you know the one thing that i i'm
wondering is when are they gonna add
another
uh class armor mod that increases your
stats like powerful friends and radiant
light does
they're currently the only two mods that
increase by 20. right yeah
they realize it was last minute
yeah i think they like released those
two and they're like
uh
oh we don't think we should have done
this but they can't just remove it i
mean i guess you know the fact that they
haven't reduced it from 20 to just 10 by
now maybe maybe it's okay maybe they
want it to be that way but
the moment they add like a void one that
maybe increases recovery by 10 or 20 or
increases strength by not strength sorry
discipline by 10 or 20. i feel like it's
going to push people a little bit more
to using you know different armor
different stuff but
yeah that's what you're going to stay in
top
i've noticed they're pushing also
into the 3.0 what is it the
aspect fragment things like if you
notice a lot of them when you play
around with them there's these huge stat
bumps or stat decreases based on how
effective they feel
you know it is so it's funny you say
that yeah i think they're still
experimenting i'm curious if if he's
going to get that 3.0 in the way
he envisions it or maybe this is the
transitionary phase before you know we
actually get a full on 3.0 a complete
revamp of armor on some level
yeah i mean even austin in chat said res
gives 40
for damage mitigation now and that was
like a recent change and all of a sudden
everybody's like
i need a new set of armor that does that
because if you're gonna go in i mean
it's like you can either have like
everybody's like well recovery still
made the most sense because if you did
get tagged
obviously getting back into the fight in
pvp makes sense but now if i'm in a
grand master nightfall if i get tagged
and i die it doesn't matter but if i get
tagged and i don't die that's that could
be a thing
there are reason there are ways that
they can do that again messing with it
slowly but yeah lightfall
we discussed this before is like what
big system changes could be
feels like it might be time for that one
so we can hope
um
yeah iron banner will
be
uh eruption we already talked about that
one but
um rift is going to be going into the
just kind of rotator playlist going
forward so you'll see it in there kind
of on that weekly rotation basis
i
honestly fish with friends with friends
that i believe that is
caviar yeah yeah yeah mine was like
mercy on either end usually but the rare
moment it was like a true match of
tug-of-war i was like just by because i
was in freelance i was like the moments
i had those was like this is what it's
supposed to be just doesn't happen that
often
uh but yeah million and a half players
played at least one match of rift 300
000 and manage you to reset your rank
150 000 reset it twice
uh we definitely hit a few people just
right one player reset their rank 17
times last season
and they did it in 55 hours
now my assumption is
they did that in the first week with the
double rep bonus because there's no way
in hell they did that in the busted
second week
another player played over 133 hours of
rift during season 17.
i mean the number of hours in those two
weeks that's not that much that they
weren't sleeping and playing riff that's
that's a lot of yeah we made you green
are you sick is that too much rift
[Laughter]
i don't know all this
talk is just kind of just getting me
just just a little bit a little bit
under the weather a little green you
know yeah a little little green little
grab
up to the shortened second uh rift
version
yeah the people who didn't have the
double experience sometimes you know
yeah yeah they look blue right there
shout out to dj what's up i see you yeah
yeah that look the the patch yeah dj
oros is out there he missed that thing
by like one hour too he's so mad
because he was he had it calculated and
the patch went one hour earlier and
missed it but
travis on the other hand shows violence
it's fine
uh but they did say you know the uh the
number of matches that fully went to
time dropped by 10 after they made some
of the mercy changes they also dropped
it to eight minutes uh they also said
having no mercy criteria to one third of
matches ending in mercy
that's a lot though i feel like that
means
again this is where i feel they're soft
and we talked about this last week and
we had shadow actually kind of pop in
and we had a good discussion um i think
the soft
uh skill based matchmaking control
it's almost like as soon if it actually
does reasonable there again don't know
if it will or not but if if the soft is
like reasonable for most ends of the
spectrum i'm going to want it more
places quickly and i feel like that
rollout's going to take a while because
some of these seasons are going to get
longer
and there's one other thing i wanted to
point out
one of my favorite things about the new
era of iron banner is the new rules we
are going to be bringing in each season
while rift won't be an iron banner we'll
be in the weekly rotator available in
week 1 18 and 14.
that already tells you next season is
longer
so i was gonna ask you guys
do you think this upcoming season we
still don't know how long they are do
you think it's your standard
you know usually they do about three
months on a cadence about 12 weeks do
you think it's going to be we now 14
how how much farther past 14 do you
think we're going do you think we're
getting a four month season
you think we're getting is this where
we're getting some of that extension
wasn't baby they do a four month season
they better bring the heat
they better bring the heat
you gotta be kidding me so i'm taking
that heat to to to another game after
the main things i'll be honest i love
that listen i love destiny too seriously
i i do i love it um just you know
towards the end of the season once
things kind of get passed if the main
uh you know seasonal activities don't
just don't hit it sometimes right there
is another season that i can think of
maybe two three seasons ago i didn't
stop playing destiny 2. i just kept on
doing the seasonal activities because it
was fun it was a lot of fun and that's
not to say the new one isn't fun it's
just
there's some activities that keep you
coming back just because they hit that
weird little notch in your brain and
they're fun and they're enjoyable this
season that was the story
right and now that that story is over
and we're waiting for the next season
it's a little bit more calm so i'm
hoping that maybe next season since
they've done a stellar job with the
story now they keep doing a stellar job
but maybe a little bit more focused with
whatever seasonal activity is coming out
and the things that we get to do for it
that that
keeps you wanting to play even after the
story is over
all right so i you know fingers crossed
if you're going to make a longer season
you got to have the content in it to
really keep people to want to play for
that long season yeah they can't pull
out a 30th anniversary pack every time
they have a
long season that's just that's right
back
uh so yeah that one i don't know like
sounds like at least a four month though
because you go 14 weeks that's a minimum
i mean it'd be three and a half if you
go 14 weeks i could easily see a four
month season
i feel like this is something we've
talked about like we've kind of
speculated so stadia we've kind of had
our speculations
where do you see the release date for
lightfall being
do you expect
12-month release window from which queen
would be february
15 month release window like witch queen
would be may
before that after that where do you feel
lightfall's gonna land for a hopeful
date obviously we won't
well
i'm wondering if
we're gonna have another witch queen
situation where they just push it out
farther you know um i know
what the reason why which queen the last
season was expended or expanded was
because of uh
the whole pandemic issue going on and
i'm sure that made it really difficult
from the develop things and so they said
all right listen we need to take this
extra two three was it extra three
is three months months
there an extra an extra three months um
in order to uh finish this and develop
it and holy [ __ ] they did amazing they
did they did fantastic with it and so i
i i kind of am possibly leaning on maybe
us having another extended season at
some point and lightfall may be coming
out a little farther out for them really
to get that chance to push in as hard as
they can with it not that i want that
but if i'm thinking about it i kind of
would prefer because seeing how
which queen came out that came out three
months earlier i think how
you can't really say exactly what
wouldn't have been made for it but i'm
sure there would have been things that
were cut out that really would not have
made that experience as amazing as it
could have been right and so
i'm i'm leaning on the the longer
uh timetable for for
uh that expansion to finally come out i
think you're with us we were i'm
somewhere in the maid apartment i think
you were what
were you like april cog were you like a
little shorter than
march you were march you're like just
about a month and then travis is out
here in september again basically for
lifefall he's just like yeah
i got other stuff to play i got reviews
to do destiny will come whenever it gets
here i got other stuff going on so no
big deal
as long as it doesn't happen around a
certain occasion i think you'll be fine
so
uh but yeah other than that they said
they are
um next next season when rift does come
around they're gonna have a little more
afk protection they're gonna have a
little more standard overtime rules
uh they also for future seasons might
experiment with 3v3 rift
i don't know how that would go if like
if you get a good team versus a bad team
it's just steamroll over and over but i
guess that's what the mercy's for yeah
smaller maps though something like
wormhaven they said they could use some
weird asymmetrical maps like burnout
uh i would say just like mess with some
of the maps i think that's what like
that's what those could be for
hey this week when if you go jump into
rift we're gonna have a couple weird
maps in there let us know how they play
like just throw them in there and
occasionally hey this is a weird map
this is a cool one cool
uh fixing scenarios where one team can
keep the other one away from the spark
and you know kill farming
also the one with big bullets is like
get rid of less black screen time after
scores because just like
okay we're good again
so they are so they're continuing to
refine rift and then we're getting like
clash 1.5 with eruption
how would you feel if in rift when you
picked up the spark the person who had
the spark had like law
how did i put this
died quicker
you have to protect the rift because
your brazil went down to zero or
something yeah or or something like that
or like weapons did twice the amount of
damage on you or something because yeah
i don't know
with the 3v3 you get a really good team
the person who just carries the spark i
believe you can still shoot yes while
you're carrying the spark so all that
becomes is just oh shoot yeah one team
rolls the other team really quickly
because they're just bringing the spark
over while killing them quickly if they
make it so the team with the spark has
that disadvantage because that third
player now has some kind of situation
the other two have to protect them it
might give you know those other teams
that opportunity to to fight it out you
know um but i'm sure that's i'm sure
there's a ton of things the development
team has been thinking of trying out um
for rift and i'm sure we're going to see
some changes here and there kind of like
that along the way
yeah i was thinking um just even from uh
the rift carrier can't shoot right so
then
it kind of puts him in a defensive
position where you kind of running with
a pack okay protect now it's a good time
to go like i was thinking more of a
rugby football kind of thing and um you
know there's ways to play with it i'm
curious the decision there with with the
gun play but yeah i hear you guys
anytime like that would be
there's things they could do out i feel
the tweak tweak it because if you really
have a
a skilled rift carry with gunplay
like you know he's gonna do
impressive to watch them if they were on
your team and if like they picked up the
spark and they dunked you're like that
was one second how'd they do that
so final thing kind of a cool thing
they're doing they are going to have a
community artist that they've already
chosen they've already worked it out
with them they're going to have a
community artist actually design an
exotic ornament they're going to kind of
do in a concept art then obviously the
in-game artists will have to make it
they did say this will be a paid thing
so they will be paid for their time
the community votes on first which of
these three exotics which i'll list off
the email is going to be coming out
around august 16th so keep your eyes on
your email you say then you're going to
vote on which weapon
then the artist is going to
make three variations of ornaments for
that exotic and then we're gonna vote
between the three variations i gotta ask
you guys and i just want a single answer
which exotic of these three do you wanna
see an ornament for arbalist
sweet business or rat king
stadia which which one do you wanna see
brad king
travis
sweet business baby
cog
list
i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna make it a a two
for arbalist so
sweet business
but the gun has been skinned to look
like a banana it's just one big long
banana that you walk around with
and it can shoot like
he's like i'm intrigued
we already went left
we are went left continue
anyway that's my proposal that's me
trying to get you to his eyes
okay so here's my logic for herbalist
i'm going to tell you about it when
you're done sweet business is basically
a meme weapon
anytime it ever gets used by people
anyway yeah it had a thousand bullets or
whatever for the broken
perk but outside of that
unless this is one of those hey we are
finally streaming long enough to get
spammed cool
thanks guys
um
but yeah so sweet business i feel like
is just a mean weapon
not really strong enough in pve it's
just not and then pvp
i don't really see it used successfully
rat king
very specific niche if you're building
around invisibility but outside of that
it's
me oh i see a little
honey
okay fine very unskilled unskilled rat
king player then
i used to main um
what was the old void bow
back before beyond light came out before
sunsetting came out there was an old
void bow i know something with an s
something with an s yeah i had one of
those for the longest time too exotic
no no no legendary legendary
hold on internet come on
oh subtle calamity it was subtle yeah
yeah yeah yeah i used to uh i used to
main subtle calamity into rat king uh as
a bow swap
and it was at the time you know at the
met with the meta at the time was
absolutely
beautiful taking someone's health down
to a hundred or even even 50 health left
swapping to that rat king getting a tap
tap or just a single tap and then taking
someone out and then getting health
regen invisibility to whip out the bow
and find someone else close range
because you know it's a sidearm you got
to get close but because of that
invisibility you get that option right
and
it's it was so good and i i haven't seen
that at all i haven't seen a both swaps
you know there's very specific weapons
that people usually end up swapping into
but honestly a bow into rat king is a
very very fun time when you start
getting that bow
that bow rolling um i highly recommend
you give it a shot racking can be very
good even if you don't have a team to to
stack that buff on there um the other
ones yeah
herbalist
i have a special feeling about art bliss
and it's not good in pvp i think people
yeah
but in pve i feel like it's going to get
used by everyone and i think that's why
for me my vote is obvious because okay
i'm going to lean pve and that's the one
that is going to get used against
literally half of the game so it's the
one that i would probably see the most
and that's where i think the artist
could probably shine the most as well
that's why i picked arbolist my monster
is completely fashion based
the sweet business looks good there's a
gold ornament already that look amazing
rat king is a sexy looking gun looks
amazing all but let's let's be honest it
is a eyesore it need a touch-up we need
to get
take take that thing out
buy some clothes [ __ ] it up you know
it needs a look it's not a sexy looking
gun at all it's effective it's a fact it
was a it's a nightfall specialist and it
had its run it's still december decent
yeah
you know what i mean but yeah i'll be
man hook that thing up so i can actually
feel good shooting
i don't feel good wait just look at it
just just
it kind of it kind of i was like there
is an ornament this season for arbalest
by the way
i don't like it
did you see the new ornament is it a new
new one there's an ornament for arbolous
this season which i picked up when it
was actually sold for bright dust it
actually looks pretty cool
um but still i'm gonna prefer arboles
just because it's the one i would use
the most by far so they
yeah you need to go buy that ornament
probably if you can't stand it but this
one kind of reminds me of like a kit
bash weapon when i look at it just the
base the base uh ornament for it or just
this base look it looks like a little
kit bash thing and i mean you know i'm
kind of in the position where like not
every weapon needs to have that absolute
you know straight sex appeal the moment
you look at it right because you build
for that appeal with your armor you know
what i mean you can get a look on it but
i agree but i listen listen i i feel
like that's why i use ariana's vow with
the actual fire ornament you know
that is actually amazing you know we
need more ornaments like that with
effect
you gotta have an ornament match to fit
you gotta make no
and look good it's a synergy like i
can't be out there with that toll bridge
looking gun that oh my god
you look like a toe riddle like a look
at trolls
like a troll is that what you're saying
yes i can't i can't see that
it's too industrial sex that thing up
make it look hot take it out get it give
it a makeover then bring it back i'll
just let's go i'll just go like dip it
in calluses pool of gold and be like
here it's your cod skin
juju give it the bad juju treatment get
that gold golden shader you know what i
mean you know how i feel about that you
know how i feel about the calorie shade
is that leviathan drip let's go oh yeah
oh yeah so timing wise though i will say
timing wise though depending on when
things release they said they were gonna
give the artist some time to develop
them and then we would vote but and then
it's gonna have to get made and put in
game season 21
is when this thing is coming out it
could be a year it could be a year from
now because if we get lightfall whether
it's march may
anywhere in there and then you go three
months after that for season 21
probably even even off of my guests at a
minimum may april or may june july or
like yeah august sometime when we see
this ornament they're gonna bring it
back up again we're gonna be like
oh yeah
like episode 257 or something when we're
talking about this so
it's gonna be a minute
yeah i like that they doing this with
the community though that's a good look
you know get the artists in there reward
the artist i like that and and ornaments
is something that i i'm always going to
stand behind so it's a cool little
initiative despite how how long it takes
yeah they're they're not rushing the
artist they're giving them plenty of
time which i do appreciate but yeah i
was like by the time this thing comes
back up i'll have forgotten about it i'm
sure so
uh that is mostly it for the twab
as for
stadia uh we gotta ask top three raids
currently that you've played
oh god
[Laughter]
i'm going to be on this spot here baby
i've never seen artists in a banana with
like anxiety
salvation honestly not going to lie is
probably one of my favorite aside from
deep stone [ __ ] because of the space
walk garden of salvation in my opinion
is just a beautiful beautiful raid i
love the looks of it when you get to
that three-fourths area that last
quarter right before atheon the giant
garden i swear to god every time i do
that raid i just sit there i i just sit
there and enjoy it um i just think it's
beautiful and uh raids like that that
kind of have those feelings where you
can just sit there and appreciate the
scenery rather than just the gameplay is
something that i really really enjoy
which is why you know the space walk
turn off that oh keep that dialogue on
you all your friends and just sit there
and vibe and just listen to that
dialogue and just have a beautiful time
and that's that's what i enjoy so much
about garnet salvation is the raid can
be a little bit not as user friendly i
still think it's a lot of fun though you
know what i mean especially um
uh like the second encounter with the
harpy everything having to make those
diagrams and like call out to your
teammates like which which eye you gotta
shoot and everything i i think the
mechanics are really really fun they can
be a little bit difficult for atheon i
agree it's a little bit weird but i just
think it's a beautiful raid and so that
is my top three at the moment um deep
stone crypt yes because of that
spacewalk i think that was such
i i i love it
just the idea of being on the outside
yeah on the outside of that giant
spaceship looking at europa you know
listening to vibing to the music looking
at the galaxies across it's
such a it's so beautiful love is pretty
talkative
why are
and then um
is vaulted glass the only other one
that's available right now is it vaulted
glass guard and salvation and deep sound
crypt we got val you've got oh val yeah
yeah yeah yeah val's kind of in that
same kind of i'm stuck between val and
vog just because i played vog in destiny
1 i believe and the emotions and the
memories of that are there so that's
kind of what i carry with it also you
know my in-game name is time so whenever
you hear and you fail at atheon and it
says
you're lost in the corridors of time you
know it just fits that just solidifies
it right there yeah exactly yeah
don't apologize i was gonna say you
could include destiny one raids in this
list as well by the way yeah
holy what the [ __ ] what am i doing yeah
oh yeah
and then also last wish riven is a bay
or if it is
yeah riven is but i am actually trying
to get like a riven plushie
i want to get a riven plushie i just
think riven is that gonna be one of
those like sleep pillows because she's
large
you got to use those tentacles or
something anyways uh yeah no but maybe a
small little plushie who knows
you know
life-size ribbon with okay anyway that
is that is where we are so i had to ask
that when you guys have any more
questions for our banana in a cup
tonight he has been fantastic
hello stadium time absolutely hilarious
great time extremely knowledgeable love
them strats i'm gonna have to apply some
of those then she would talk in a day
that was really cool but yeah but a lot
of fun good talk swab too oh i never got
a chance to bring up my favorite weapon
in the game you said favorite exotic and
i told you it was ariana's about to
bring up my favorite weapon yeah well
you know i'm a bowman you know i'm a
bowman and there's a very specific bow
in destiny 2 that i don't think gets
enough love and that is my honey
biting wins
really and the reason why i love
love love love love biting wins is
because it is the only bow in the game
currently
precision frame bow that has
swashbuckler and the beautiful part
about swashbuckler is when you have it
proct it can one shot headshot any
resilience guardians for five seconds
after a melee kill right charged melee
or regular melee and the way that i play
my build because i already told you guys
i go for those freeze rift freeze into
melees
yeah yeah yeah a lot of the time that's
how i end up wiping teams in trials is
because i'll catch someone on that
freeze rift around a corner and i
purposely aggressively push towards them
i get that melee and for five seconds i
can one shot headshot and then if i get
a kill resets the timer back to five
seconds you keep on rolling the dice
constantly it is it is crazy especially
for um just getting one shot in mayhem
if you get one melee kill it'll body
shot it's hilarious it'll body shot
instant kills you just go around just
boom boom boom it's so much fun and
people need to give it a shot seriously
swashbuckler on biting wins is is a game
changer i would go as far as to say um
biting wins with swashbuckler is one of
if not the best bows in the game even
contending against lemonark people just
aren't aware of it because they don't
want to try any other weapons
actually just got because i was going
through
doing a little bounty prep i got one
with
swashbuckler and rapid hit on biden wins
with real master work not bad not bad
i wouldn't use it the same way you would
but still not bad
um
yeah i actually i mean that is a bow
that i've got i think i literally have
two of them master worked one is killing
away and one is surplus on it for um
watch buckler both of them do and draw
time and everything else so noah's like
i put some time in with that bow it does
it does feel pretty good i will say
about bows in general and destiny i
never expect when they're like a bow in
a gun game i'm like
what why
and then i get it in my hand i'm like i
love both
yeah i've actually
i i always
i think in most of my solo runs
solo flawless destiny or dungeon runs
almost all of them have included a bow
for some section i think
i can probably figure that one
i mean it's nice to have that
really long range high damage oh yeah
yeah i mean usually scout rifles can
take that spot but with bose having
gotten a damage buff for red bars i
believe in
that's nice having a weapon that you can
give do those long range shots and a
really fun um pve bow uh i think the new
strident whistle can get this role and
wolf tone draw yeah was my baby wolf
town wolfton with harmony is beautiful
um shoot to loot dragonfly because in
pve when you kill a pve enemy that
dragonfly will automatically pick up any
ammo they drop because of the loop it
doesn't work in pvp for some reason but
pve very very nice for long range like
high nightfall i guess gameplay where
you're running out of special running
out of heavy oh shoot you killed that
one red bar there one yellow bar with
one shot explosion boom you got all your
ammo back if they dropped anything it's
great it's a lot of fun
yeah i've been trying to get
incandescent with something decent on
that bow and i finally got i'm like two
resets into vanguard so i'm still trying
to get that one with incandescent just
to explode some heads for entertainment
value but
yeah now i've been enjoying i'm glad to
see we have another solar bow back
because that was uh scarce territory for
a while
um
yeah
well
mr stadium banana cup it has been
absolutely fantastic
in a banana cup oh my goodness
i feel like you need to
like fill the cup up with a little bit
and then like lean back to the side
where you're like just soaking in the
tub kind of situation
well i mean i had a few other things
over here i was going to like throw up
or something you know as we were like
just practicing or just talking about
certain stuff you know what i mean
remember earlier said like hey is anyone
into attack on titan you know what i
mean yeah you know talking about you
know
okay
[Laughter]
one of the ones that i was practicing
with that i was just like rising up and
on the stream i'll just have the music
like the theme song playing and i'll
just be i'll just like
this is how we finish it up if you're
not watching video you're missing the
spiderman kiss you said that was one oh
yeah we'll probably have to do that
spiderman kisses sometime right i mean
if we did it i'd have to fight you so
it's kind of like you know whatever
i saw you bringing out that saber
this is always a little bit of a
gymnastic thing because i actually got
to get up
you know
contrary to popular belief i i actually
physically do every single little thing
i'm doing so if you saw me in real life
you think i was really [ __ ] weird
yeah
your spouse comes in uh
do we need to have you checked is
everything okay
all right time to do some gymnastics all
right let's just see what we're doing
okay careful now okay okay
okay i love having a little he's like
flailing because
wow this is talent y'all i gotta find my
angle here listen it's not easy to do a
handstand while you're banana
yo
this
there we go he dope in this cup
oh there it is
[Laughter]
if you can do a handstand at all that
means yeah
final thing apparently we need an anime
intro
oh
i do have a i do have an intro that i do
for my things the only issue here is the
fact that you can't hear the audio the
audio is fun um but
i can i can play it you might have to i
saw you cropped my uh my thing a little
bit tighter uh so unless you open it up
just a little bit so you can see the
rest of it
one of the fun things that i've done
with the stream um is those like you
know custom little intros that i'll do
for fun so one of the fun ones i'm just
gonna put it to the brb screen that i
have is this
that's funny this
oh that's kind of perfect
salute stadium time with a building bug
peel perfect that's
beautiful
oh that's great
if you guys don't watch this man's
streams you are missing out on a lot of
entertainment so please please make sure
you go find
well now's the time tell everybody where
they can find you what you do what the
what you know what's the schedule any
and all things the platform is yours to
say it all so
yeah so i'm i'm mostly at the moment
active uh on twitter and that's just
because you know i just landed a new job
so now i'm trying to figure out
apartment stuff i got to move out by the
end of the month so when it comes to
streaming it's a little bit difficult
for me to do right now i haven't done it
since the uh the bungie charity
fundraiser um that i was asked to do
oh yeah that was that was it was a
really fun time honestly like anytime i
get a chance to raise money for that
cause it's it's a fantastic time
seriously um
but uh you can find me uh stadiatime
spelled exactly like that on both
twitter and uh twitch and then on
youtube it's just time i don't use
youtube as much but i'm starting to just
post any like little meme videos that i
post on twitter which is usually where
it goes but yeah
oh very nice
fantastic time gotta enjoy the content
please love what you're doing community
just
just have fun you know the creativity
with it
it's a unique thing and uh you've
created elaine and you have made this
your own i absolutely love it it's
hilarious sometimes i can't look at you
directly because i'm going to keep
laughing
kind of like
okay well actually the greatest thing
about just doing this and not just
having a camera is when i do trials
carries if we ever get beaten really
really really bad because we're doing a
carry versus and then it's a three stack
or something and they jump to the stream
and they're like haha [ __ ] and
laughing like they look at the banana
and they're like what
and then
and then we just have a good time or
like when we beat a team right and then
maybe they come in and maybe they're all
angry you can't get angry at this come
on
you're gonna look like a fool yeah so
it's like you know
exactly so it's just a fun way to like
defuse the situation like it is the
ultimate icebreaker yeah seriously
i do have to ask um
halloween please tell me you've been a
banana for halloween oh oh yeah yeah
yeah okay
there's a picture that's floating around
in my discord server uh of my halloween
costume
nice nice
oh yeah and during halloween i try to
you know the other nice thing about this
is during seasonal events i can just go
a little wacky so instead of being in a
mug i was in a little pumpkin i was a
little pumpkin with a little fire inside
of it it was a lot of fun we do we do
some fun little seasonal things when it
comes to
when it comes to just
you'll be easy to spot at gcx next year
in your banana costume so it'll be
perfect
costume and not the hammock tissue
yeah you know if you wear it if you wear
the banana hammock out of the
jewelry okay you know we'll make sure we
show up the hobie is okay that's it
let's talk about those cones baby
we finally finally found somebody who
dresses weirder than me i'm very happy
it feels good to feel normal y'all
yeah
my gimmick it's over there that's that's
today's dude
he's always here in suits like this is
like half banana peel over here what's
happening yeah you guys give me [ __ ] for
wearing a three-piece suit at gcx wait
till i'm standing next to this guy
[Laughter]
uh well gentlemen my co-host what else
you guys got coming up this week
anything to call out or you know things
to look forward to travis
yeah uh my review of digimon survive
will probably be up early next week
probably tuesday or wednesday um
uh i'll have a preview for construction
simulator probably around the same time
um you can check out my review of
xenoblade chronicles 3 on ign.com
and you can follow me on twitter at
tigeytravis if you want
and uh yeah it's exciting great to have
you on the show stadium time feel free
to come back at a later date and uh i
look forward to
photos see him later
god did it cuter by the second
you know i seriously i had a fantastic
time i really appreciate it i think
there's something
really fun and enjoyable about having
like a group of people to speak to at
the same time on a one-on-one thing it
can be very nice it's very you know it's
an intimate thing you talk to each other
and you throw things back and forth but
when you have like a like an entire
group of people being able to talk about
stuff it just feels like you keep on
going forever you know and especially
when you got a group of guys like you
that just
radiate
that absolute appeal you know what i
mean so
man this banana is trying to butter us
up over here
yeah he let that one slip all right
here we go
oh oh
[Laughter]
this is a classic episode clearly again
salute to stadium time absolutely
hilarious a lot of fun great time you
know be on act on twitter cognito i love
podcasts every sunday
don't want to jinx the guess because if
it doesn't happen but all right i'll say
we supposed to have
jason rubin from naughty dog the og
supposed to pull up the creator of crash
bandicoot creator
so many of classic franchises so
hopefully you know it still is on
it it will go down so we'll do that and
then uh check out me and maddie on
defining duke should be up for patreons
go check that out talking about
everything that's going on in the
industry all that good stuff and uh
support some other ones escaping that
that man i know we ain't ign and
everything but you know
we got some cool people over there you
know they're kind of cool check it out
and uh shout out to also uh me maddie we
did a as does full spoiler cast so i'm
gonna check that out and learn about the
game after you played it your choices
and all that good stuff and uh yeah
that's pretty much it for me what about
you e what's going on uh first thing i
want to say thank you uh stadia for
joining us seriously you're welcome back
anytime if you're like all right i
haven't talked to people about destiny
in a while i feel like it's time hit us
up you are welcome this was
way too much fun uh i figured it would
be i don't know if i figured it would be
as much fun as it was so thank you for
an absolute blast if you guys did not
catch if you listen to us on audio form
we appreciate the listens but i will
recommend you go check out the video
whether it's on iron lord's podcast or
on my channel either one is well worth
the watch even just skim through for a
couple of fun moments there great the
last five minutes apparently could be
worth it um
alone and yeah for me uh kind of working
on that possible review game that i got
early access to cultural land comes out
thursday next week and then i'm just
trying to
slowly spread out a little bit of bounty
prep because then we have the three or
four days of absolute hell at the start
of the season between
trying to cover what's going to come out
guides for that and then the raid on
friday
it's going to be a busy few days so yeah
that's kind of what i'm trying to spread
things out and work on stuff around the
house as well i literally just got done
doing something else in my house today
so
yeah good times um but yeah thank you
guys thank you chat you guys were
hilarious stadia travis cog thank you
all for being here tonight
absolute pleasure oh
pleasure was ours on this one i'm pretty
sure so
thank you all for being here for episode
number 209 we will see you guys next
week with legionless tv thank you guys
have a good one and for this episode it
has been
the last
word
i gotta point to the screen again here
we go